okay today I'm going to talk to you
about elasticity calculations we're
going to see how these two different
calculations work and how they apply to
real-life situation okay so the first
one we're gonna look at is f equals K
times X to begin with it's really
important to know what this means so I'm
going to show you this situation here
here we have a spring and here we have
the same spring after it had this
hanging mass added to it so as you can
see the spring has been extended by the
force of this mass here so f stands for
force in Newtons
so here let's imagine that this has a
force downwards of 10 Newtons okay next
up we need to know what this K
represents now K represents this thing
called a spring constant now the units
for spring constant are Newtons per
meter
now all this thing as spring constants
constant is is it depends on the
material that you're stretching a
stiffer spring has a greater spring
constant so this number here depends
completely upon the type of spring that
you're using now finally this X
represents X tension extension so that's
why the X comes in extension and it's
measured in meters now all extension
means is how much has the spring
extended so this here is our x value
extension now let's say in this
circumstance it's 10 centimeters now as
you can see because extension is
measured in meters we need to convert
this to meters really quickly so that is
0.1 meters so quite often in
question for example you might be asked
to find the spring constants from this
particular situation so with this force
and with this level extension what is
the spring constant now first of all we
have to do a little bit of rearranging
so the force is 10 your spring constant
we don't know what that is we're trying
to figure out the spring constant of
this particular spring and finally a
value for extension is 0.1 meters
now we need to rearrange this equation
to make K the subject of the equation in
order to do this we need to at the
moment we've got K divided at times 0.1
on this side so in order to counteract
that we need to divide both sides by 0.1
so that way that's a 0.1 as well so
we're dividing both sides by 0.1 so on
this side we're doing 10 divided by 0.1
which therefore equals K okay so I'm
basically them the same to both sides to
make K the subject to the equation now
the next thing I need to do is 10
divided by 0.1 so 10 divided by 0.1
which equals 100 so in this particular
instance I'm just going to write it the
other way around so it's nice like this
okay equals a hundred Newton's per meter
now this value is just particular for
this particular type of spring based on
its stiffness okay so the other type of
grace by the way we need to for edexcel
GCSE 9 to 1 we need to remember this
equation here we don't need to remember
this equation here we just need to know
how to how to apply it how to apply our
knowledge to it
okay so let's imagine we're looking at
the exact same situation but now we know
the spring constant we want to see the
work done the work done during this
extension basically if there is a if
there's a linear relationship between a
force and extension we can apply this
equation to find how much energy is
transferred during this extension so
right now we're trying to find how much
energy is being transferred during this
extension okay so all we need to do is
put the numbers in so we have so also
just make that clear first he stands for
energy transferred okay
and that's course is measured in joules
now it's also another way of saying this
is work done so as the spring extends
how much energy is being transferred how
much work is being done so now we know
the spring constant we just need to put
the numbers into the equation so e
equals 1/2 now I prefer put in 0.5 when
I put it into a calculator times K now
if you remember K is the spring constant
this particular spring constant of this
spring we've just found out it is a
hundred so we do 0.5 times 100 times x
squared now this squared is really
important a lot of people miss this out
when they put it into their calculator
okay so remember the extension how far
the spring extended was 0.1 and we
square it so all I need to do is put all
of that into my calculator remember to
put it all in at once and because of big
mass it does that squared first so my
answer is 0.5 so my energy my work done
the amount of energy
transferred is 0.5 joules so here we've
basically just a recap this equation we
can use the idea of 4/6 ention to find
the spring constant if we do a little
bit of smart rearranging and just here
we could find the energy transferred in
a particular situation as long as we
know the spring constant and the
extension as well and remember another
term for energy transfer in this context
is how much work is being done thank you